Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is Restless History with me, Tom Holland. Sitting opposite me is the ever-lovely Dominic Sandbrook. You're very kind, Tom. And Dominic, last week we were talking about greatness. Missed myself out. So I guess a complete lack of modesty is a central attribute of greatness
感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。我是汤姆·霍兰，与我相对而坐的是永远可爱的多米尼克·桑德布鲁克。你太客气了，汤姆。多米尼克，上周我们讨论了“伟大”这个话题。我自己给漏掉了。所以我想，极度缺乏谦逊正是伟大的核心特质之一
aside from yourself um i mean we we went through a lot of great people last week um in the intervening week have you come up with any great people because you see we didn't talk about writers musicians we didn't talk about shakespeare or mozart or the beatles so actually it's not just about we were wrong it's not just about killing people and scoring goals. It's also about, you know, well, that's a whole podcast in itself, isn't it? OK, so Elvis, the Beatles, they'd be great. OK, well, today I thought that we could talk about civil war. Nice.
除了你之外，嗯，我是说，我们上周讨论了很多伟大的人物，嗯，在过去的一周里，你有没有想到什么伟大的人物？因为你看，我们没有讨论作家、音乐家，我们没有讨论莎士比亚、莫扎特或披头士乐队。所以实际上，这不仅关乎——我们之前说错了——不仅关乎杀戮和进球。这也关乎，嗯，好吧，这本身就是一个播客主题，不是吗？好吧，所以埃尔维斯、披头士，他们算得上伟大。好吧，今天我想我们可以聊聊内战。不错。
Not a cheery topic. Jolly subject. Prompted specifically by an amazing poll i saw um well you saw because i gave it to you yeah it's and it's sitting right here in front of me um in which um americans who identify as democrat or republican it says um one in three now believe that violence could be justified to advance their party's political goals uh and this year in america we've seen kind of armed militias starting to roam the street i mean it's what's the difference between a fraying of
这不是一个轻松的话题。一个令人愉快的话题。这主要是由我看到的一个惊人的民意调查引发的，嗯，其实是你看到的，因为我把民调结果发给了你的，对，它就摆在我面前的桌上，嗯，民调显示，嗯，自认为是民主党人或共和党人的美国人中，现在有三分之一的人认为，为了推进本党政治目标，使用暴力可能是正当的。而且今年在美国，我们看到一些民兵武装开始在街头游荡。我的意思是，这其中的区别在哪里呢？治安的瓦解
civil order and full-scale collapse into civil war what what are the lessons of history on that um if you're about to collapse into um civil war yeah do you know when it's coming yeah do you know when it's coming so what what would you say the less what are the lessons of history there on that oh easy subject see i this is something that's always um fascinated me because i can remember going to university at about the point when the yugoslav civil wars were kicking off and yugoslavia was a country that existed throughout my entire childhood. You know, football team, anthem, flag. Winter Olympics.
与内战的全方位爆发之间有什么区别？历史对此有何教训？嗯，如果你正走向内战的边缘，嗯，你知道它什么时候会到来吗？你知道它什么时候会到来吗？那么，你会怎么说——历史对此有什么教训呢？哦，这是一个轻松的话题。你看，这件事一直让我着迷，因为我还记得上大学的时候，正值南斯拉夫内战爆发，而南斯拉夫是我整个童年时代都存在的一个国家。你知道，有足球队、国歌、国旗。冬奥会。
The Winter Olympics in 1984. Torval and Dean. Torval and Dean in Sarajevo, I think it was. So, you know, Yugoslavia was a sort of fixed point in the Atlas. You know, you learned that Belgrade was the capital. People went on package holidays in the 80s. It was a very trendy kind of package tour destination. And then it implodes. And then it fell apart in that incredibly gruesome way.
1984年的冬奥会。托维尔和迪恩。我记得是在萨拉热窝的托维尔和迪恩。所以，你知道，南斯拉夫就像是地图上的一个固定坐标。你知道，你知道贝尔格莱德是首都。人们在80年代去那里参加跟团旅游。那是一个非常时髦的旅游目的地。然后它突然崩塌了。然后它以那种极其可怕的方式四分五裂。
I mean, any listeners of our age will remember, you know, neighbor turning on neighbor because of religious differences, because one was a Bosnian Muslim family and one was a Bosnian Serb family. And that sort of terrifying sense that everything can just fall apart you know almost sort of JG Ballard I mean um nightmare can become real so quickly I mean yes and so it's it's the fact that it's happening in in a European modern European state yeah I mean that's terrible to say so but that's obviously part of the impact isn't it that it was so close but I guess I mean one thing that thing that strikes me about the way that Yugoslavia implodes is that it was a kind of, it was an artificial nation.
我的意思是，我们这个年纪的任何听众都会记得，邻居对邻居刀兵相向，仅仅因为宗教差异，因为一个是波斯尼亚穆斯林家庭，另一个是波斯尼亚塞族家庭。那种恐怖的感觉，即一切都可能分崩离析，你知道，几乎有点像J·G·巴拉德的小说。我的意思是，噩梦竟然能如此迅速地变成现实。我的意思是，是的，这就是它发生在一个欧洲现代欧洲国家的事实——我的意思是，这样说很糟糕，但这显然是冲击的一部分，不是吗？因为它离得如此之近。但我想，我的意思是，让我对南斯拉夫崩溃的方式感到震惊的一点是，它是一种，它是一个人工合成的国家。
Yeah, but all nations are artificial, aren't they? Yeah, but it was stitched together from the constituent parts of the Austro-Hungarian Empire and the Ottoman Empire. So these empires that that had collapsed and then in a sense after the the second world war it although it wasn't officially part of the warsaw pact it was part of the the communist sphere of influence yeah so in that sense it was it was kind of frozen by the cold war and it's when the berlin Wall comes down and the Cold War ends that the ice melts and all these kind of ancient hatreds have been busy incubating. I don't agree with that. I don't think it is ancient hatreds. That was an argument. Ancient hatreds was actually a phrase used in the 1990s in the White House by the Clinton administration to justify not intervening.
是的，但所有的国家都是人造的，不是吗？是的，但它是从奥匈帝国和奥斯曼帝国的组成部分中拼凑出来的。所以这些帝国已经崩溃了，然后在某种意义上，二战之后，尽管它不是华沙条约国的正式成员，但它是共产主义势力范围的一部分。所以从这个意义上说，它被冷战“冻结”了。而当柏林墙倒塌、冷战结束时，坚冰融化了，所有这些一直在暗中滋生的古老仇恨……我不同意这种说法。我不认为这是什么古老仇恨。那只是一个论点。“古老仇恨”实际上是20世纪90年代克林顿政府在白宫使用的一个词，用来为他们的不干预政策辩护。
They said, oh, it's all these ancient hatreds of these people who are all basically tribesmen who hate each other. So what do you think causes it? I think it's, you know, you look at all these civil wars, you look at Spain in the 1930s, even if you look at England in the 1640s, and the patterns are not so different. You see this sort of escalation of rhetoric, this belief that the other side pose a mortal threat
他们说：“哦，这都是这些人的古老仇恨，他们基本上都是互相仇恨的部族成员。”那你认为是什么导致的呢？我认为，你看所有这些内战，比如20世纪30年代的西班牙，甚至如果你看1640年代的英格兰，模式其实并没有那么大差异。你会看到这种言论的升级，这种认为对方对国家健康以及对你和你的社区构成致命威胁的信念。通常还有一个宗教层面的因素。你会看到……我觉得这要归咎于戴克里先。戴克里先？是的，罗马皇帝戴克里先。公元三世纪末的罗马皇帝，实际上把罗马帝国一分为二，所以你有西部，也有东部，你有东正教，也有天主教，而断裂线几乎完全吻合……这就是南斯拉夫，是的，就是这样。我把这个观点也抛出来。但你看，我也认为另一个地方，嗯——你提到了奥斯曼帝国，是的，当然，在过去十年里因内战而被最残酷地撕裂的国家是叙利亚。是的。伊拉克也发生过内战。
to the health of the nation and to you and your community. There's often a sort of religious dimension. You see think i think it's down to diocletian diocletian yeah roman emperor diocletian the roman emperor at the end of the third century who effectively divides the roman empire in right in two so you have the uh the western half and you have the eastern half you have orthodox and you have the catholic and the fracture line is almost exactly onto uh this is yugoslavia yeah yeah that's it i throw that i throw that into the mix but but you see i think also another another place where um you mentioned the ottoman empire yeah and of course the the the country that is most has been most savagely torn to pieces by civil war over the past decade is Syria. Yeah. And you've had civil war as well in Iraq.
我认为有一种感觉，同样，这两个国家都是从奥斯曼帝国的残余中拼凑出来的人造实体。有一种观点认为，内战往往在民族国家中孕育，而这些国家以前可能是帝国框架的一部分，在其中，民族国家的概念根本毫无意义。但是，好吧，我稍微能接受这一点。所以你有这种所谓的“人工创造物”，它们天生就带有这些分歧。
And I think there's a sense that, again, both countries are kind of artificial entities stitched together out of the tatters of what had been the Ottoman Empire. And there is a case for saying that civil wars get incubated in nation states that perhaps previously had been part of imperial frameworks in which the idea of the nation state made no sense at all. But that's, okay, I can buy that a little bit. So you've got these sort of what you call artificial creations where they're sort of baked in with these differences.
但接着你看20世纪30年代的西班牙。所以西班牙是一个有着数百年历史的国家。当然，30年代的西班牙也有分裂主义运动，但西班牙是一个看似合理、合理的民族国家。甚至在没有分离主义的地区，人们仍然在屠杀他们的邻居。我记得大约三四年前读过一本书，对我产生了巨大的影响，书名叫保罗·普雷斯顿的《西班牙大屠杀》。基本上，这本书的论点是，西班牙发生的事情——对反对派的非人化，以及
But then you look at Spain in the 1930s. So Spain is a country with centuries of history. Of course, there are separatist movements in Spain in the 30s, but Spain was a sort of plausible, reasonable nation state. And even in areas with no separatism, people still killed their neighbours. When I remember reading a book about three or four years ago, which made a massive impression on me, called The Spanish Holocaust by Paul Preston. And basically, the argument of this book was that what happened in Spain, the dehumanisation of the opposition and the
认为消灭他们是一件符合道德的事——与四五年后纳粹主义在欧洲中东部发生的事情没有太大区别。实际上，那些个体的故事……我的意思是，我记得有一个村庄，那里的地主和他的朋友们基本上把村里所有他不喜欢的人都围捕起来，然后他们对这些人进行了一场类似斗牛的活动，让他们绕着体育场跑，接着他们就屠杀了他们。他们把所有人都杀了。这种事在一个又一个村庄、一个又一个城镇发生，而那里根本没有什么宗教差异，除了……
belief that killing them was a moral thing to do, was not so different from what happened in Central and Eastern Europe, you know, four or five years later under Nazism. And actually, the individual stories, I mean, there's one village I remember where the landowner and his friends basically round up all the people in the village who he doesn't like, and they do a sort of mock bullfight with them, get them to run round the stadium, and then they butcher them. They kill them all. And this sort of thing happened in village after village, town after town, where there were no religious differences other than...
但仇恨会呈指数级增长，不是吗？嗯，但这才是最可怕的地方，不是吗？你看，我们以为自己能幸免。真的吗？嗯，但这才是最可怕的地方，不是吗？你看，我们以为自己能幸免。真的吗？嗯，这是一个有趣的问题，因为我们在英国经历了一个政治分歧变得非常非常激烈的时期，而且我们正生活在一个这样的时代：在社交媒体上，
But hatred kind of grows exponentially, doesn't it? Well, that's the terrifying thing, though, isn't it? See, we think we're immune. Well, do we? Well, that's the terrifying thing, though, isn't it? See, we think we're immune. Well, do we? Well, that's the interesting question, because we've lived through a period in Britain where political differences have been very, very highly charged, and we are living in a time when, on social media,
人们经常说他们的对手是邪恶的，他们纯粹是出于恶毒，他们的动机仅仅是贪婪或仇恨，诸如此类。我的意思是，左翼会说右翼的坏话，右翼也会毫不犹豫地攻击左翼。这些就是冲突的先决条件。因为如果你真的相信你的对手不是完全的人类，那么你为什么不杀了他呢？我想之所以没有发生这种情况，是因为那些这么想的人在推特上太忙了，根本没空走上街头。对，是的。
people regularly say that their opponents are evil, they are purely maligned, they're motivated only by greed or hatred and all the rest of it. I mean, the left will say that the right and the right of the left completely happily. And those are the preconditions for conflict. Because if you really do believe that your opponents are not properly human, then why wouldn't you kill them? I suppose the reason that it hasn't is that everyone who thinks that is too busy on Twitter actually to get out on the streets. Right, yeah.
但当然，我的意思是，联合王国境内确实发生过内战，如果不在大不列颠本岛的话，因为北爱尔兰在70年代实际上就是内战的现场。它基本上就是一场内战。所以在20世纪70年代初，你知道，贝尔法斯特每年都有数百人被杀。
But of course, I mean, we have had a civil war within the United Kingdom, if not in Great Britain, because we've effectively, Northern Ireland was, you know, in the 70s, was a scene of effectively of civil war. It basically was a civil war. So in the early 1970s, you know, you have hundreds of people being killed in Belfast every year.
到处都有炸弹爆炸。我想在1972年左右的某个时期，贝尔法斯特基本上每天都会发生一起炸弹爆炸。你走进商店，去上班，你都必须经过军事检查站。到处都是士兵。到处都是坦克。街上到处都是武装准军事人员。
You have bombs going off. At one point, I think, in about 1972, you basically have a bomb going off in Belfast every single day. And you go into the shops, you go into work, you have to go past military checkpoints. There are soldiers everywhere. There are tanks. There are armed paramilitaries in the streets.
我的意思是，这与17世纪整个大不列颠和爱尔兰的内战已经非常接近了。是的。所以从某种程度上说，这是……的一个持久遗产。好吧，我不知道你是否同意这一点，但人们总是说，特别是那些非常善良的老师、那一类信仰的人会说：“如果我们了解历史就好了，如果我们多了解一点历史，我们就会对彼此那么好，一切都会变得非常美好。”
I mean, that's as close to a civil war as the the whole of Great Britain and Ireland in the 17th century. Yeah. So in a sense, it's been an enduring legacy of... Well, I don't know if you'll agree with this, but the people always say, and particularly very well-meaning teachers, people of that sort of denomination will say, if only we understood history, if only we knew a bit more history, we'd be so kind to each other and it would be really nice.
但在我们谈论过的每一场战争中，特别是南斯拉夫和北爱尔兰，历史在某种程度上正是罪魁祸首。正是因为人们对历史有着如此强烈的感知，是的，我……你知道，也许人们少了解一点历史会更好。我认为确实如此，并且我认为，正是当根植于宗教或民族意识形态的身份认同与同样强烈的其他身份认同发生摩擦时，冲突才会爆发。我想这就是30世纪30年代西班牙发生的事情，各种意识形态的紧张局势被卷入其中，这些紧张局势特别孕育自20世纪，然后它们与更古老的宗教和国家身份认同融合在一起，但是……
In every war that we've spoken about, particularly Yugoslavia and Northern Ireland, it is history that is in some part the culprit it's because people have such a strong sense of history yes i you know maybe people knew less history i think that's true and i think i think it's um it's when um identities that are rooted in religion or in an idea of nationhood um rub up against equally strongly held ones that that you get it and i suppose that's what that that that's what happens in in spain in the 30s is that thrown into that mix is kind of ideological tensions bred specifically of the 20th century that then kind of fuse with with much older religious and national identities um but
但你刚才在开始时问到，是不是有一个时间点，你知道，你会看到警报铃响起？你能看到警报铃响起吗？你能听到警报铃响起吗？是不是有一个时间点，你能听到警报铃在响？我想知道那个时间点是什么，因为通常情况下，你知道，比方说80年代的英国——我写过关于这个的内容——当时的言论极其激昂。通常情况下，你知道，成千上万的人……为了“全格里夫之战”。是的，好吧，我的意思是，1984至1985年发生了矿工大罢工，矿工和警察在那里进行了一场激烈的、尽管并非全面武装的战斗。但是警察举着防暴盾牌。是的，警察举着防暴盾牌。
but you were asking at the beginning about whether is there a point at which you know you see the alarm bells ring can you see an alarm bell ring you can hear an alarm bell ring is there a point at which you can hear the alarm bell ringing and i wonder what that point is because often you know let's say britain in the 80s which I've written about, the rhetoric was incredibly impassioned. Routinely, you know, tens of thousands of people... To the battle of all grief. Yeah, well, I mean, you've got the miners' strike in 1984-85, where you've got miners and police sort of doing, having a pitched, albeit sort of not fully armed battle. But the racks of the police with the shields. Yeah, the racks of the police with the shields.
是的，警察举着盾牌，警察的马匹向矿工冲锋。你知道，警察会说：“看，我们没收了这些武器，也就是纠察队员带来的那些简易武器。”所以双方显然都有暴力行为，人们会将其视为某种……你知道的，一场未被承认的内战。
Yeah, the racks of the police, the shields, sort of the police horses charging the miners. You know, the police would then say, well, we've confiscated these weapons, the sort of makeshift weapons that Pickett's had brought. So there was obviously violence on both sides and people would talk about it as a sort of, you know, as an unacknowledged civil war.
现在，它并不是一场内战，因为人们没有互相杀戮，也没有造成巨大的死亡人数，但那种激情并没有什么不同。显然，在那个时候，警报铃正在拉响，因为人们，你知道，在报纸上，人们在说：“这是一种可怕的局势，你知道，我们是不是在滑向更严重的事情？政府必须采取行动，政府绝不能煽动事态——正如撒切尔夫人被认为所做的那样。”难道不是吗？在法国，关于阿尔及利亚的问题——阿尔及利亚是否应该……是的，阿尔及利亚曾是法国本土的一部分，但戴高乐随后决定放手，是的，难道这……
Now, it wasn't a civil war because people didn didn't kill each other, and there's no great death toll, but the passions are not so different. And obviously, at that point, the alarm bells were going off, because people were, you know, in the newspapers, people were saying, this is a terrible situation, you know, are we sliding towards something more serious, the government must get a grip, the government mustn't inflame things as mrs thatcher was perceived to have done and and you you probably isn't it true that in france over the issue of algeria whether algeria should yeah which was part of metropolitan france but the goal then kind of cut it loose yes isn't it i mean that's
这有点像《豺狼的日子》里的情节，对吧？好吧，将领们试图……阿尔及尔发生了一场政变，嗯，如果我没记错的话，大概是在1961年左右，我可能记错了。阿尔及尔发生了一场政变，阿尔及尔当时是法国的一部分，是阿尔及利亚的首都。将领们试图……他们认为可以以此为跳板夺取法国本土的政权，并基本上建立一个军事政权，使阿尔及利亚继续留在法国。当时曾有过这样一个时刻，你知道，冲突会不会演变成武装冲突？我的意思是，并没有，因为将领们最后怂了。当时到底有多接近爆发？
the kind of the plot of the day of the jackal is it is well the generals tried to there was a coup in algiers um uh what day to be doing i think about 1961 if i remember right i might be wrong there was a coup in algiers which was then part of france the capital of algeria um the generals tried to they they they thought they would use this as a springboard to take over France itself and to basically impose a military regime that would keep Algeria part of France. And there was this moment when, you know, could it have come to armed conflict? I mean, it didn't because the generals lost that nerve. How close did it come?
我觉得其实并没有那么接近。我的意思是，大概和……但是，你知道，有趣的是，几年后的1968年，你知道，有一定年纪的人都会知道我在说什么，当我提到1968年的“五月风暴”（événements），也就是巴黎街头的骚乱，学生向警察投掷鹅卵石，汽车厂罢工等等。戴高乐极其著名地消失了。
I don't think it did actually come very close. I mean, kind of on a level with a... But, you know, what's interesting is that a few years later, in 1968, you know, everyone of a certain age will know what I mean when I talk about the événements of 1968, the kind of riots in the streets of Paris and students throwing cobblestones at the police and car factories on strike and all the rest of it. And de Gaulle famously disappears
他飞往西德巴登-巴登的法国军事基地，主要是为了争取军队的忠诚，因为他认为自己可能不得不带着军队回来打一场内战以保住自己的地位。所以就在不久前，是的，法国还是一个内战观念完全有可能发生的国家。是的，是可以想象的。是根深蒂固的。我的意思是，你们曾被德国人占领，有过维希政权，有过抵抗运动，有过解放。20年后怎么就不能发生内战呢？
he flies off to the French military base in Baden-Baden in West Germany to basically get the loyalty of the army because he thinks he's going to have to come back with the army to fight a civil war to retain his position so as recently as that yeah France was a country where the idea of a civil war was possible yeah it Yeah, was conceivable. Was embedded. I mean, you've been occupied by the Germans, you've had Vichy, you've had the resistance, you've had the liberation. Why wouldn't you have a civil war 20 years later?
是的，是的。好吧，我想作为对你关于“你知道内战什么时候会爆发吗”这一问题的回答，如果追溯到古代，我想最著名的例子就是尤利乌斯·凯撒渡过卢比孔河，你知道，“渡过卢比孔河”已经成为……是的。那么这有什么意义呢？
Yeah, yeah. Well, I mean, I suppose in answer to your question about do you know when civil wars are going to start, going right back, I suppose the most famous example of that would be Julius Caesar crossing the Rubicon, which, you know, crossing the Rubicon has become... Yes. So what's the significance of that?
是不被允许的，将领是不被允许渡过这条河的。如果你把时间推得足够远，你会发现古希腊和古罗马的古代城邦发生的事情，无一例外都归结为个人的野心。凯撒的情况绝对就是这样。是的，他在高卢待了10年，痛击阿斯特里克斯和所有这些人，并且觉得理应受到极大的尊贵和尊重。问题是，他的成就以及他获得总督职位的方式在罗马本土树敌众多
You're not allowed, a general is not allowed to cross the river. So you push things back far enough, and what happens in kind of the ancient states of Greece and of Rome is that invariably comes down to personal ambition. And that's absolutely the case with Caesar. Yes, that he's been off in Gaul for 10 years, beating up asterisks and everyone like that and feels that he is entitled to to be treated treated with great honour and respect. The problem is that his achievements and the way that he obtained his governorship has created so many enemies back in Rome
以至于有人迫不及待地想要摧毁他，而且他们想通过法律手段来摧毁他。所以只要凯撒一放下兵权，他就会变成一个平民，然后他就可以被起诉，从他的敌人的角度来看，希望他能因此身败名裂。所以凯撒想要的是，无缝衔接从高卢总督变成执政官，中间绝不当平民。而他的敌人则设法把他逼入这样一种境地：他要么选择放下兵权、回国当平民并冒着身败名裂的风险，要么就掌握着
that he has people who are desperate to destroy him and they want to destroy him legally. So the moment Caesar lays down his command, he becomes a private citizen and then he can be prosecuted and hopefully, from the point of view of his enemies enemies ruined so what caesar wants is to go seamlessly from being governor of gaul to becoming consul with no point become being a private citizen and his enemies kind of move maneuver him into a situation where he's he has the choice of laying down his command and going back being a private citizen risking risking ruin or keeping hold of his
兵权。当他渡过卢比孔河——这条河是他的省份和意大利的边界——的那一刻，他实际上就是在宣战。但这与我们之前谈论的例子不同，因为那是由于一个人的野心引发的。是的，绝对如此。不过当然，凯撒之所以能够指挥军队并获得忠诚，是因为他利用了大众的不满情绪。好吧，所以这种不满情绪是存在的，它是潜在的。是的，但我认为凯撒可以说是这样一个人——好吧，我想如果没有凯撒，共和国可能无论如何也会崩溃。但他绝对是那场内战的推手。
command and in crossing the rubicon which is the boundary between his province and italy that's quite the moment he does that then then then effectively he's declaring but that's different from the examples we've talked about before because that's generated by the ambitions of one man yes absolutely absolutely except of course that the reason that caesar is able to um command troops and loyalty is that he's tapping into mass resentment. OK, so the resentment is there, it's latent. Yes, but I think that Caesar is kind of an example of someone who, well, I suppose without Caesar, maybe the Republic would have fallen apart anyway. But he's definitely the driver of that civil war.
而对于我们谈论的更现代的内战来说，那种这就像是政治体内的某种癌症的感觉……是的，但它们也有推手。你看，它们也有推手。这又回到了“古老仇恨”的说法。所以南斯拉夫本不会发生——我的意思是，可能会有一些冲突，但如果不是斯洛博丹·米洛舍维奇的话，就不会是那种规模了。
Whereas with the more modern civil wars that we're talking about, the sense that this is like a kind of cancer in the body politic... Yeah, but they have drivers too, though. See, they have drivers too. That goes back to the ancient hatreds thing. So Yugoslavia wouldn't have happened. I mean, there might have been some conflict, but it wouldn't have been the same if it hadn't been for Slobodan Milosevic,
他是塞族人的领导人，故意煽动局势，宣称塞族人在这些分裂出去的共和国中受到迫害。然后其他一些共和国的领导人同时也点燃了他们自己的人民的情绪，宣称：“我们必须拿起武器，我们必须武装我们的警察，我们必须摆脱塞族人，等等等等。”所以基本上，人们是在故意往烈火中浇汽油。我的意思是，这不就是最近发生在，比方说，英国政治中的那种被高度武器化的版本吗？
who was the leader of the Serbs, deliberately inflaming the situation by saying that Serbs were being persecuted in these sort of breakaway republics. And then the leaders of some of these other republics firing up their own base at the same time and saying, we must take up arms, we must arm our police, we must be free of the Serb, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. So basically, people are deliberately pouring petrol on the flames. I mean, isn't that just a very, very, very weaponized version of what's been a very, very, very weaponised version of what's been happening in, say, British politics recently?
这就是问题所在，不是吗？是吗？因为很显然……好吧，我不知道。我的意思是，你是现代历史学家。你告诉我。好吧，我的意思是，我当时在想的是……所以米洛舍维奇这个人物，米洛舍维奇这个点燃了自己阵营情绪最终导致全面崩溃并引发内战的人物
This is the question, isn't it? Is it? Because obviously... Well, I don't know. I mean, you're the modern historian. Tell me. Well, I mean, what I was thinking about was that... So the figure of Milosevic, the figure of Milosevic who fires up his base and it all implodes and then results in civil war
我的意思是，这有什么不同？这不就是那个模式吗？是的，这与其他任何政客有什么不同？我的意思是，你说得对，实际上现在一个更令人不安的问题是：民主政治本身是不是一种反常现象？是一个失败的实验？不是的。它是一个，它是不是内战的一种升华版本？它内部是否带有内战的种子？换句话说，如果两个政党在一个议会大厅里对着对方大喊大叫，彼此指责：“你们在背叛国家，你们，你们太贪婪了，你们只关心自己，你们在失败，人们正因为你们而死”——我的意思是，我们现在经常听到这种话。你们在背叛国家。你们太贪婪了。你们只关心自己。你们在失败。
i mean how is that different that that's the model yeah how is that different from any other politician i mean you're right that actually now arguably a more sort of unsettling question is you know is democratic politics itself a kind of aberration a failed experiment no um is it is it a um is it a sort of sublimated version of a civil war and does it have the germ of civil war in it so in other words if you have two parties screaming at each other across a chamber and they say to each other you know you are betraying the nation you are oh you are greedy you are only interested in yourselves you are you are failing people are dying because of you i mean we hear this now You are betraying the nation. You are greedy. You are only interested in yourselves. You are failing.
人们正因为你们而死。我的意思是，我们现在无时无刻不在听到这样的话。所以在英国的语境下，难道不是因为我们有“女王陛下的忠诚反对派”这个概念吗？是的，我觉得你这话没说错。这难道不是内战留下的遗产吗？完全是的，因为你需要反对派成为内战的一部分，因为你需要——完全是因为你需要反对派，因为问题——你知道，我的意思是，不仅仅是——不仅仅是……嗯，克伦威尔护国公时期之前的那些内战，我的意思是，暴力和动荡在英国和爱尔兰持续了
People are dying because of you. I mean, we hear this now all the time. So in the British context, it isn't the fact that we have the idea of Her Majesty's loyal opposition. Yeah, I think you're right about that. Is that not a legacy of the civil wars? Exactly, because you need the opposition to be part of the civil wars because you need exactly because you need the opposition because the pro you know i mean it's not just it's not just um the um the the civil wars that precede the cromwellian protectorate i mean wars violence unrest persists throughout britain and ireland
几十之久。我的意思是，真的，一直持续到卡洛登战役，你大概可以说。而那种经历，那种对于政治体内部某些派别拒绝承认其反对者合法性会导致什么后果的理解，是一个深深烙印在英格兰和苏格兰社会肌理中的教训。我想你是对的，我认为发生的事情……你看，我的理论是，我以前……我们在高级水平考试（A-level）中学过英国内战，我一直着迷于这样一个事实：我们停下来，我想，大概是在……
for decades to come i mean really right they're up to culloden i suppose you could say and the the experience of that the understanding of where um factions within the body politic that refuse to acknowledge the legitimacy of those who are opposing them can lead is a lesson that kind of burns itself into the fabric of England and Scotland. I think you're right, and I think what happened... You see, my theory, I was always... We did the English Civil War at A-level, and I was always fascinated by the fact that, you know, we stopped, I think, with maybe...
我们学到了查理二世，然后我们在“光荣革命”之后就停下来了，我想。所以我们基本上学了，你知道，从詹姆斯一世到奥兰治的威廉。我一直很好奇，接下来发生了什么？因为所有这些一直在互相残杀的家伙们，为什么他们突然开始去咖啡馆谈论南海泡沫经济并阅读《格列佛游记》了？为什么他们不再互相打了？因为那些问题依然存在。显然发生的情况是，战争极其具有创伤性。人们基本上不再诉诸暴力，因为某种程度上，英国
We went into Charles II, and then we sort of stopped after the Glorious Revolution, I think. So we sort of did, you know, from James I to William of Orange. And I was always interested, what happened next? Because all these guys who've been killing each other all this time, and why do they suddenly start just going to coffee houses and talking about the South Sea bubble and reading Gulliver's Travels? Why aren't they still fighting each other? Because the issues are still there. And clearly what happened was that the wars had been utterly traumatic. And the people basically stopped resorting to violence as that in a way british
政治变得稍微没有那么大烈度地被武器化了。是的，所以你知道，就在1642年英国内战爆发前夕，查理一世的首席大臣斯特拉福德伯爵被处决了……通过议会通过的一项法案。所以他被处决了，你知道，他被判刑基本上是因为他执行了主子的命令。而处决，弹劾和处决，曾是一种政治上、合理的政治工具。显然，到了后来的某个时候，你就不再处决你的政敌了。你知道，2010年没有人处决戈登·布朗，2015年也没有人处决大卫·卡梅伦。我的意思是，他们甚至都没有被流放。
politics became slightly more de-weaponized yeah so you know in just before the english civil war broke out in 1642 um charles the first chief minister the earl of strafford had been executed um by after an act passed by Parliament. So he'd been, you know, he was condemned for basically doing his master's bidding. And execution, impeachments and execution, were kind of political, reasonable political tools. There's obviously a point later on where you just stop executing your opponents. You know, no one executed Gordon Brown in 2010 or David Cameron in 2015. I mean, they weren't even exiled.
我以为卡梅伦被流放到他的棚子里了，不是吗？是的，他是被流放了。他的豪华棚子里。是的。他过着一种……是的，但你宁愿被流放到豪华棚子里，也不愿被砍头吧。是的，我的意思是，我不知道。
I thought Cameron was kind of exiled to his shed, wasn't he? Yes, he was. His posh shed. He was. He's living a kind of... Yeah, but you'd rather be exiled to a posh shed than have your head chopped off. Yeah, I mean, I don't know.
我的意思是，我不知道大卫·卡梅伦在棚子里过的是什么生活。我的意思是，我住的地方离大卫·卡梅伦其实不是很远，所以我很容易就能查出来。好吧，是的，下周去查查然后回来汇报吧。我有着惊人的懒惰。这个想法，我的意思是，我想这就是民主党人和共和党人关于民调的那个想法最让人不安的地方，一个运转良好的民主制度
I mean, I don't know what life's like in David Cameron's shed. I mean, I don't actually live very far away from David Cameron, so I could easily find out. Well, yes, go and do that next week and report back. Extraordinary laziness that I have. It's the idea, I mean, and I suppose that's what's so unsettling about that idea of the poll of Democrats and Republicans thinking the same, is that a functioning democracy
取决于极端派别是否承认多元主义的合法性。除非你具备这一点，否则你其实并没有一个运转良好的民主制度。但在政治上，肯定是在现代政治史中，有时这种多元主义会磨损，我认为。所以如果你说，我们谈论过80年代，如果你回到80年代，当时有一个阶段，在某种程度上，双方都否认对方的合法性。你知道，玛格丽特·撒切尔的定义性特质之一就是，她基本上不说社会主义者是错的。她说他们是邪恶的。他们是邪恶的力量。同样地，她的反对者也这样说她：她不仅是错的。她奉行的不仅仅是错误的政策。她是一个真正的邪恶之人。
depends on extremes acknowledging the legitimacy of the pluralism. Unless you have that, then you don't really have a functioning democracy. But there are times, politically, certainly in modern political history, where that pluralism frays, I think. So if you say, we talked about the 80s, if you go to the 80s, there was a point there where, to some extent, both sides denied the other's legitimacy. You know, Margaret, one of Margaret Thatcher's sort of defining qualities was that she basically didn't say socialists are wrong. She said they are evil. They are their forces of wickedness. And equally, her opponent said of her, she's not just wrong. She's not pursuing just wrong policies. She is a genuinely evil person.
是的，但在任何时候，撒切尔或金诺克都没有否认对方在下议院起立发言的权利，你知道，他们没有开始进口武器来分发给他们的政党。但是，你知道，在首相质问时间，撒切尔站在那里，金诺克作为民选首相质问她，是的，你说得对。并且同样地，撒切尔接受作为民选工党领袖的金诺克的质问，而那种……那种摩擦确实存在于工党的极左翼——那里有人否认资产阶级民主的合法性——以及在右翼——那里有人幻想政变和军事接管。只要这两个极端被控制在极端状态下，你就会拥有一个运转良好的民主制度。一旦他们开始……但我们
Yes, but at no point do de thatcher or kinnock deny the right of the other one to stand up in the house of commons and you know they don't start importing arms to distribute their party but but you know prime minister's question time thatcher stands there and kinnock questions her as the duly elected prime minister yeah you're right and and and likewise thatcher takes questions from kinnock as the duly elected um leader of the labour party and the the the kind of the the fraying is is there on on the the kind of the hard left of of labour where there are people who deny the legitimacy of of bourgeois democracy and on the right where there are people who kind of fantasize about coups and and and military takeovers and that that's always as long as they that those two extremes are kept on the extremes then you have a functioning democracy once they start kind of um but we're
现在正处于一个更危险的时代，不是吗？因为民主的主流比我们有生之年见过的任何时候都更受质疑。我的意思是，年轻人对民主的信任度更低，特别是那些最有可能引发内战的人，因为他们年轻、活跃，而且他们没有按揭贷款。嗯，而且，我的意思是，众所周知，如果不是内战的话，大规模国内动乱的推手之一就是找不到工作的大学毕业生。是的，这正是我们目前正在走向的局面。中场休息后，我们将迎来更多的国内动乱。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。
in a more dangerous time now aren't we because the sort of the mainstream of democracy is more discredited than it ever has been in our lifetimes. I mean, trust in democracy is lower among young people, particularly with the most the people always most likely to drive a civil war because they're young and they're kind of active and then they don't have a mortgage. Well, and also, I mean, famously, one of the drivers of if not civil wars and then then mass civil unrest is graduates who don't get jobs. Yes, that is precisely where we're heading. We'll have further civil unrest after this break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
这是你们每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你们这一切是如何运作的。如果你想要收听无广告的音频、加更节目并提前获得现场门票，我们已经推出了会员俱乐部，请前往 therestisentertainment.com，也就是 therestisentertainment.com。回到我们开始时谈到的美国，我认为那里的情况令人担忧的是——与英国相比——武器的数量。我的意思是，这才是打内战所需要的东西。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest of the entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com to go back to america which is where we started, I think what's worrying about that, as opposed to Britain, is the number of weapons. I mean, that's what you need to have a civil war.
所以基本上，英国内战的爆发是因为双方都想把武器弄到手，他们都想把军队、国王和议会控制在自己手里。在美国——我的意思是，在北爱尔兰，他们之所以能互相残杀，是因为他们有武器。他们进口了枪支。在美国，他们已经有枪了。我的意思是，我们都看过那种画面：有些人
So basically, the English Civil War starts because both sides want to get their hands on weapons and they want to get their hands on the army, the king and parliament. In the US, I mean, in Northern Ireland, they could kill each other because they had weapons. They had imported guns. In the US, they have guns already. I mean, we've all seen the footage of sort of people
在“黑命贵”抗议活动期间，手里拿着半自动步枪站在自家前门廊上。你不觉得这很令人担忧吗？是的，我通常觉得人们拥有大量枪支的想法很令人担忧，但那是因为我是一个非常英国式的懦夫。是的，对此有点紧张。而且你还有唐纳德·特朗普，你知道，
during the Black Lives Matter protests standing on their front doorsteps with their, you know, semi-automatic rifles. Don't you find that worrying? Yeah, I generally find the idea of people having lots of guns worrying, but that's because I'm a very English wuss. Yeah, slightly nervous about that. And you've got sort of Donald Trump, you know,
在选举结果出来之前，他也尽最大努力去将其合法性剥夺，顺便说一句。那种民主本身不再合法的意识。是的，所以这就是……是的，所以基本上你必须尊重选举的合法性和程序。当你不这么做时，风险就来了，我想。
doing his best to delegitimize the election result before it happens as well. That sense of democracy itself not being legitimate. Yes, so that is... Yeah, so essentially you have to respect the legitimacy of elections and the process. And when you don't, that's when the risk is, I guess.
你认为——我知道你对诸如联合王国的未来之类的事情有强烈的看法——你认为英国本土未来有没有可能发生某种内战，例如，如果其中一部分试图脱离……嗯，不，我……我无法想象，如果这是苏格兰人民离开联合王国的意愿，英国政府会反对这一点。
And do you think, I mean, I know you have strong views about things like the future of the United Kingdom. Do you think it's ever plausible you could have a kind of civil war in the UK itself, for example, if part of it tried to break away um i no i i i can't imagine that um if it's the will of the scottish people to leave the uk that that a uk government would would oppose that
诺森伯兰郡的人民不会拿起武器去强迫他们的邻居……不。我的意思是，我是……你知道，英格兰和苏格兰合并是有原因的，那就是……金钱。是的，好吧，金钱，但也为了，你知道，那是苏格兰人的金钱，也是英格兰人的一种愿望，为了保护
people of northumberland won't take up arms to compel their neighbours to... No. I mean, I am... You know, there's a reason why England and Scotland joined, which was that... Money. Yeah, well, money, but also, you know, it was money for the Scots and it was a desire to kind of protect
英格兰北部的边界。看看这些因素——那些曾促成联合王国合并的因素，
the northern frontier for the English. And it'd be interesting to see whether, you know, the, the factors that, that, that, that influenced the, the joining of the United Kingdom,
如果联合王国解体，它们是否会重现，这将是一件很有趣的事。我的意思是，我不知道，但我不会对此感到过分担忧。我，
whether they would recur if the UK came apart. I mean, I, I don't know, but I, I, I wouldn't worry about that so much. I,
我的意思是，我认为，当你想到诸如17世纪英国的内战或是美国内战时，你会发现，你对战争为何而打的理解必须随着时间的推移而演变，甚至在事后看来也是如此。所以美国内战就是一个典型的例子，现在我们认为它是为了废除奴隶制而战，但在某种意义上并非如此。我不知道，它一直都不是，不是吗？我不知道——我的意思是，它是非常……你本来想说是为了南方各州的 secession（分离）权利……
I mean, I think, I think one of, one of the things that, that when you think about say the, the civil wars in Britain in the 17th century or indeed the American Civil War, is that your sense of why a war is being fought must evolve over time and indeed retrospectively so so with the american civil war being the classic example that now we think of it as having been fought about slavery but but there's a sense in which that wasn't i don't know it was always wasn't it i don't i don't know if i i mean it was very you're going to say it was about the right of secession of the southern
嗯，我认为——我认为其根本原因是为了奴隶制。但我怀疑，当时正在参战的人是否认为这是为了奴隶制而战。这是一种在战争进程中演变出来的观念吗？同样，在英国的内战中，人们对于他们到底在为什么而战的理解，我猜在战争刚开始时是非常不同的。在英国的内战中，人们对于他们到底在为什么而战的理解，我猜在战争刚开始时是非常不同的。那是，你知道……是的，因为在一开始，我认为没有人是在为打仗而打仗——显然，内战，英国内战就是一个很好的例子，其中的意义发生了变化：在开始时，没有人是为了推翻国王而战，
states well i i think i mean i think in its fundamentals it was about slavery. But I'm wondering whether it was seen as having been about slavery by people who were fighting at the time. Was that a kind of idea that kind of evolved over the process of fighting? And likewise in the Civil War in Britain, the understanding of what people were fighting about, I would guess, was pretty different at the beginning in the civil war in in in britain the understanding of what people were fighting about i would guess was pretty different at the beginning of the wars it was you know yeah because at the beginning i don't think anyone was fighting i mean obviously the civil wars the english civil war is a great example where the the meaning changes so the beginning nobody is fighting to get rid of the king yeah and certainly nobody is fighting for a republic but at the end of the war
当然也没有人为共和国而战。但在战争结束时，人们并不这样认为——查理·斯图尔特，他们认为查理·斯图尔特是一个双手沾满鲜血的人，他必须被处决。军队里有真正的共和派，在接下来的10年里，他们一直在与任何企图——他们所看到的对士兵中扎根的激进愿景的开倒车行为——进行斗争。所以我想，这是内战（与其他战争相比）经常发生的事情之一，那就是你有一群非常投入的普通士兵。
people didn't think that charles stewart does they charles stewart is a man of blood yeah and he has to be killed and there are proper republicans in the army who then for the next 10 years are fighting any attempt what they see as sort of backtrack on the radical vision that has taken root among the soldiers so i think one of that that's one of the things that often happens in a civil war as opposed to another war i think is that you have a very engaged consequences yeah you have a very engaged kind of rank and file because they're fighting on home soil they're fighting for hearth and home they're fighting against their neighbors it all just means much more yeah and then they become radicalized over time and i think that that to that extent extent, you could say that, say, the tensions that have afflicted Britain over this decade, kind of the same thing has happened. That things have happened that people would not have anticipated.
结果，是的，你有一群非常投入的普通士兵，因为他们是在本土作战，他们是为了家园和炉火而战，他们是在与邻居作战，这一切都意义重大。然后随着时间的推移，他们变得激进化了。我认为，在某种程度上，你可以说，困扰英国这十年的种种紧张局势，其实也发生了类似的事情。有些事情发生了，是人们预料不到的。
That perhaps the Brexit vote has unleashed arguments and tensions and crises. People did become radicalised, didn't they? Yeah. But it was a de-weaponized yeah thankfully thankfully but but you can kind of see that that um civil wars mutate ideologically yeah they do but also i think tom what one of the disturbing things about them is that you know brexit is a good example actually because there you have an issue that you know everybody has an opinion but most people probably don't have an intensely strong opinion, that a lot of the sort of the shouting is done by a relative minority. But
或许脱欧公投引发了种种争论、紧张局势和危机。人们确实激进化了，不是吗？是的。但这被去武器化了。是的，谢天谢地，谢天谢地。但你也能看出，内战在意识形态上会发生突变。是的，它们的确会。不过我也认为，汤姆，其中令人不安的一点是——你知道，脱欧就是一个很好的例子，因为在那里你有一个所有人都持有观点的话题，但大多数人可能并没有极其强烈的观点，许多叫嚣的声音其实来自于相对少数的人。但是
that's true in civil wars, too. Yeah, most of the people, I mean, if you ever read interviews of people in the Yugoslavian civil war in the 1990s, or indeed in Spain in the 1930s, a large proportion that would say, actually, I wasn't really, I didn't want a war, I wasn't really that bothered. It was my neighbours who had always been incredibly political who drove this, and the rest of us were sort of swept up in it. And that's the scary thing. I mean, in the English Civil War, I was identified with the club men.
内战中也是如此。是的，大多数人——我的意思是，如果你读过任何关于20世纪90年代南斯拉夫内战或20世纪30年代西班牙内战中人们的采访，很大一部分人会说：“实际上，我并不是真的很想打仗，我其实没那么在乎。是那些一向极度热衷政治的邻居推动了这一切，而我们其余的人只是被卷了进去。”这才是最可怕的事情。我的意思是，在英国内战中，我曾把自己等同于“俱乐部人”（Clubmen，指英国内战期间试图保护家园不受交战双方掠夺的英国地方自卫武装）。
Oh, yeah. So tell us about the club men. Because I grew up in Wiltshire, and the club men were very strong in Wiltshire. They were people who basically didn't want to fight on either side. So they'd fight both. So they would get clubs, hence their name, anding from all the debate going living in the wood. And kind of wondering, well, you know, what would it take to precipitate an actual civil war in a modern Western liberal democracy? You know, is it the definition of living in a Western liberal democracy that it can't go?
哦，是的。所以给我们讲讲俱乐部民吧。因为我在威尔特郡长大，俱乐部民在威尔特郡势力非常强大。他们基本上是不想支持任何一方的人。所以他们两边都打。于是他们拿起棍子，因此得名，他们从所有的辩论中抽身出来，住在树林里。然后有点在想，好吧，你知道，在一个现代西方自由民主国家里，要发生什么才会引发一场真正的内战？你知道，西方自由民主国家的定义就是它不会发生这种事吗？
No, of course it can happen. Of course it can happen. So how would it work? Well, I suppose it would be preceded by a period, let's say 10 years, possibly longer, of growing passion, intense politicisation. This is why I think apathy is so underrated. Yes. Because the more, you know, if you ever want to find somewhere where everyone cares about politics, they're talking about politics, which is what sort of politicised people want. Yeah. That place is Spain, 1934. You don't want to be there.
不，当然会发生。当然会发生。那会怎么运作呢？嗯，我想它之前会有一段时期，比方说10年，可能更长，充满着不断增长的激情和强烈的政治化。这就是为什么我认为冷漠被严重低估了。是的。因为越是……你知道，如果你想找一个每个人都关心政治、都在谈论政治的地方，而这正是那些热衷政治的人想要的。是的。那个地方就是1934年的西班牙。你可不想去那里。
Happy the land that takes no interest in politics. Right, exactly. So I think you have an intensely politicised public. You have young people, so the people who are most likely to fight. Basically have young people who are on the streets, who maybe don't have jobs. Yeah, and who feel that they are not getting the jobs, that their education... They've got nothing to lose. They've got nothing to lose. I think you have a sense of sort of dehumanisation or delegitimisation.
不问政治的国家是有福的。对，完全正确。所以我想你会有一个极度政治化的公众。你会有一群年轻人，也就是最有可能去打仗的人。基本上街上会有年轻人，他们可能没有工作。是的，他们觉得找不到工作，他们的教育……他们没有什么可失去的。他们没有什么可失去的。我认为你会有一种去人性化或去合法化的感觉。
So your opponents are not just wrong, they're evil. And the process itself is worthless and flawed. So there's no point in persisting with it. I mean, I think there is the way that Trump has been trying to argue that he's not going to leave. I mean, that's a kind of major step. But it's kind of there on the left as well. Because the question, you know, if Trump wins, would people opposed to him accept it? I mean, I can't imagine they would either.
所以你的对手不仅是错的，他们是邪恶的。而且这个过程本身就是一文不值、充满缺陷的。所以坚持下去毫无意义。我的意思是，特朗普一直试图争辩说他不会离开，我认为这算是一个重大的步骤。但左翼也有这种倾向。因为问题在于，你知道，如果特朗普赢了，反对他的人会接受吗？我的意思是，我无法想象他们会接受。
At what point, if you're the governor of California, do you just say, sod it? It's the seed. Yeah, but I think the other issue is, you know, to have a war, you have to be able to kill people. So you either have to have paramilitaries with access to weapons, so they're getting there from outside, so the intervention of some foreign powers, or you have a very politicised military. So in other words, the army will step in
如果你是加州州长，在什么情况下你会直接说：去他的？这就是萌芽。是的，但我觉得另一个问题是，你知道，要打仗，你必须能够杀人。所以你要么得有能获得武器的准军事部队，也就是他们从外部获得武器，因此有某种外国势力的介入，要么你有一个高度政治化的军队。换句话说，军队会介入
and will fight on one side, or there are elements of it that might fight on the other side. But I mean, I have to say that, I mean, all of these conditions are clearly, but I'm relieved to think that they are all pretty unlikely so well some of them are i mean i mean i think in britain for example the one that is the least likely is actually probably the military um and in that you know in the 70s there was talk of this happening yes man batten was man batten and his coup so lord man batten supposedly was going to
并在其中一边作战，或者军队里有可能会为另一边作战的成分。不过，我的意思是，所有这些条件显然都……但我欣慰地认为，它们其实都相当不可能。嗯，不过其中一些……我的意思是，我认为在英国，举个例子，最不可能发生的一点其实可能就是军队，嗯，你知道，在70年代曾有关于这会发生的讨论，是的，蒙巴顿勋爵和他的政变。所以蒙巴顿勋爵据说要
lead a coup to install a government no it wasn't true but it was in the crown it must be true so the most famous story is that Cecil Harmsworth King who was basically the um the boss of the Daily Mirror he summoned Mountbatten he used to keep in his desk this is the late 60s he used to keep in his desk a list of his cabinet when he became emergency prime minister which is an unusual thing for a newspaper i mean maybe it's not maybe all newspaper workers do this i'm sure we can all think of newspaper editors who probably do have lists in their desks of of their government when they assume supreme power but anyway cecil king had this list and matt batten was on it and he basically arranged a lunch with matt batten in which he said here's the story um I want you to take over as dictator and the Daily Mirror will support you. And Mountbatten sort of was,
领导一场政变来组建一个政府。不，这不是真的，但既然上了王冠（电视剧），那就一定是真的。所以最著名的故事是塞西尔·哈姆斯沃思·キング，他基本上是《每日镜报》的老板，他召见了蒙巴顿。他以前的抽屉里藏着——这是60年代末——他抽屉里一直藏着一份名单，是他成为紧急首相时的内阁成员名单。这对于一家报社来说很不寻常，也许也并非如此，也许所有报社员工都这样做。我确信我们都能想到某些报社编辑，当他们夺取最高权力时，他们的抽屉里可能确实有内阁成员名单。但无论如何，塞西尔·金有这份名单，蒙巴顿就在名单上。他基本上安排了一场与蒙巴顿的午餐，在午餐上他说：事情是这样的，嗯，我希望你接管政权成为独裁者，《每日镜报》会支持你。蒙巴顿当时大概是……
you know, he didn't know what to make of it. He basically didn't make anything of it. I think supposedly he went back to the Queen Mother and said, I've just had the most extraordinary conversation with a friend of yours. And it was never really mentioned again. But when the Mirror found out about it, they basically booted out Cecil King as their chairman.
你知道，他不知道该作何感想。他基本上没把它当回事。我想据说他回去对王太后说：我刚刚和你的一个朋友进行了一次极其不同寻常的谈话。然后这件事就再也没有真正提起过。但是当《镜报》发现这件事后，他们基本上把塞西尔·金作为董事长给踢出了公司。
I think if a chairman is plotting civil war, I think that's fairly reasonable. Well, it was risky. I mean, if he'd succeeded, they would all have been for the chop, presumably, or maybe exiled to the Isle of Man or something. But anyway, there were stories that in the 70s, this would be discussed at Sandhurst and whatnot. You know, what will happen if people come to us and they say, we need to step in, you know, the trade unions are taking power
我想如果一个董事长在密谋内战，这算是相当合理的吧。嗯，这很冒险。我的意思是，如果他成功了，他们所有人大概都会被砍头，或者也许会被流放到马恩岛什么的。但无论如何，有传言说在70年代，桑赫斯特军校之类的地方会讨论这种事。你知道，如果人们来找我们说，我们需要介入，你知道，工会正在夺取权力
and we need to arrest all the leaders of the TUC and the Labour Party or something. And generally, as far as I understand, the mood was, this is ridiculous, we wouldn't have anything to do with it. And I think Britain is in a relatively fortunate position of having a relatively unpoliticised military that's hard to imagine taking part. But the United States is slightly different. I mean, if you're there, you've got the president is the commander-in-chief.
我们需要逮捕工会联合会（TUC）和工党的所有领导人之类的话，会发生什么？总的来说，据我所了解，当时的气氛是：这太荒谬了，我们才不会参与这种事。我认为英国处于一个相对幸运的位置，拥有一个很难想象会参与其中的、相对去政治化的军队。但美国则略有不同。我的意思是，如果你身处其中，总统就是三军统帅。
The president gives you an order. You have to follow it. Or you're breaking the chain of command. So imagine that the election in the US. I mean, in the US, a lot of those conditions have been met, haven't they? There is the delegitimizing of the process. There is already violence on the streets. There are a lot of guns. There are people who genuinely believe that their opponents are evil and are out to get them and are going to steal all their money or kill their kids or all this kind of business. imagine a situation which is an electoral deadlock
总统给你下达命令。你必须遵守。否则你就是在破坏指挥链。所以想象一下美国的选举。我的意思是，在美国，许多这样的条件已经具备了，不是吗？存在对程序的去合法化。街头已经有暴力事件。有很多枪支。有些人真心相信他们的对手是邪恶的，想要加害他们，打算偷走他们所有的钱或者杀死他们的孩子，诸如此类的事情。想象一下陷入选举僵局的情况
the president as commander-in-chief refuses to leave gives the army a direct order you know governors give their their police forces different orders dominic i i thought that we'd end on this note because it would be a kind of cheery note because i in no way thought that you'd go for we haven't even gone into France yet. ...full civil war. But it's still, you know, let's end on a positive note. Very unlikely, isn't it? But is it, though?
总统作为三军统帅拒绝离任，向军队下达直接命令，你知道，州长们向各自的警察部队下达不同的命令。多米尼克，我以为我们会以这种轻松的调子结束，因为这是一个令人愉快的调子，我绝没想到你会走向……我们甚至还没讨论法国……全面的内战。但这依然，你知道，让我们以积极的调子结束吧。极不可能，对吧？但真的是这样吗？
Well, yes. So I don't know. I mean, how long... I think... Let's say we've both got, what, how many years left? Let's be optimistic. We've got 30, 40 years left until we're dragged off to the great archive in the sky.
嗯，是的。所以，我不知道。我的意思是，还有多久……我认为……假设我们俩都还有，什么，还剩多少年？让我们乐观一点。我们还剩30、40年，直到我们被拖进天国的大档案库。
In that time, is it plausible that we will see some sort of breakdown of order, some kind of violence in an industrialised, in a vertical, developed country? I'd have thought so, but I wouldn't have thought... We will, won't we? I wouldn't have thought that it would be a kind of traditional civil war. I think it's likely to be prompted by climate emergency... See, I think civil wars have been a constant of human history.
在那段时间里，我们是否有可能看到某种秩序的崩溃，在工业化、高度发达的国家里发生某种暴力事件？我原以为会，但我不会认为……我们会，对吧？我不会认为那会是一种传统的内战。我认为它更有可能是由气候紧急情况引发的……你看，我认为内战一直是人类历史中恒久不变的现象。
Well, yes. I'm hearing your gloomy Spenglerian pessimism. The difference in conventional wars, right, is that a conventional war becomes less and less likely because the stakes are so high the technology is so but a civil war you're not going to drop a nuclear bomb on somebody
好吧，是的。我听到了你那阴郁的斯宾格勒式的悲观主义。传统战争的区别在于，常规战争变得越来越不可能，因为赌注太高，技术太……但内战，你总不会朝某个人扔一颗核武器吧。
but butchering your neighbour with a kitchen knife I suppose what I can see is something akin to Northern Ireland so ulsterisation never an open civil war but just bombings, paramedics on the streets of Luxembourg. Well, I think on that note,
但用厨房菜刀屠杀你的邻居……我想我能看到的是类似于北欧尔兰的情况，也就是“阿尔斯特化”——永远不是公开的内战，而只是爆炸，卢森堡街头出现急救人员。好吧，我想顺着这个话题，
I think we have nowhere to go after that. So, we will draw a line on that, which I think it's not been a cheery conversation. No, I think listeners should tweet us and suggest their own favourite civil war. listeners should tweet us and suggest their own favourite and say why Dominic's wrong cheer me up
我想我们之后无路可走了。所以，我们要就此划清界限，我认为这不是一次愉快的对话。不，我认为听众应该在推特上@我们，推荐他们自己最喜欢的内战。听众应该在推特上@我们并推荐他们最喜欢的（内战），然后说为什么多米尼克是错的，来让我高兴点。
on that sombre note we will bid you have a lovely day bid you farewell thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com.
带着这个忧郁的调子，我们祝大家度过美好的一天，向大家道别，感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家分集、提前解锁、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。
That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
网址是 restishistorypod.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。